if you can and knowing you're hampered
by the situation of the meeting can you
tell us anything about that meeting with
the DOJ up on Capitol Hill today yeah I
was a classified briefing of what we
call the gang of eight which is the
leadership of the House and Senate along
with the Intel committee leaders and I
really can't because it was a classified
briefing and that's what classified
means yeah is there were you surprised
with what you learned nothing
particularly surprising but again it was
classified so there's no real no real
report I won't go down there's this
whole but should Congress be privy to
this material if it is part of this
investigation
yeah I think Asian aliy briefing the
they get the gang it's no call gang of
eight is a good idea for the
administration they agreed to do it we
were glad they did about this
investigation and broadly about the
Russia probe the former National
Intelligence director James clapper is
out with a new book and he accuses you
and speaker Ryan of essentially not
caring about foreign interference in the
2016 election as long as President Trump
won in this book he writes quote I was
disappointed but not surprised it seemed
they'd had decided by then that they
didn't care who their nominee was how he
got elected or what effects having a
foreign power influence our election
would have on the nation as long as they
won your response to that sir well it's
almost laughable I mean the
administration and the various players
involved in under estimating the whole
episode have been looking around for
others to blame that's an absurd
suggestion clapper knows better and he
should have shouldn't have written it do
you think that this investigation is
coming closer to an end I have no idea
but I think it would be great if we got
to do
and got to a conclusion sometimes son
let me turn to today's news about the
North Korean summit the summit in
Singapore that's now been called off
your reaction to that I think the
president did the right thing you know
we've seen three generations of North
Korean leaders engage in similar ploys
in order to get relief from sanctions it
seems that the Kim jong-nam is a chip
off the old block
and I think the president didn't want to
be played with wanted to make sure the
North Koreans understood he was serious
willing to engage provided they didn't
continue to play these kind of games
that they've historically done with
other administrations they've gotten
away with it so in some I think
President Trump did exactly the right
thing in canceling the the meeting as
far as diplomatic moves is your sense
that the hope in the White House and the
expectation is that this is somehow
going to get back on track eventually
yeah I think we all hope it will I mean
there's nothing that wouldn't be good
about a Korean Peninsula without nuclear
weapons so sure we all we all hope this
gets back on track and the next step it
strikes me is up to the North Koreans
yes or no will you cancel part of the
part or parts of the August recess yeah
I'll have more to say definitively about
that the week after next but I've said
that all the press corps and the members
up here I wouldn't buy an eight
non-refundable tickets right and there's
a tweet from Burgess Everett saying I
told Senator McConnell I delayed my
August vacation his response was you
should and I guess the question is if
the Congress can't get what it needs to
get done from January through July how
much will a couple extra weeks help you
well Brooke this has been a period of
extraordinary accomplishment the notion
that
this Congress hasn't been doing anything
as utter nonsense disproved by the facts
this has been the most productive
year-and-a-half in the time I've been in
the Senate and I'm now in my third
decade particularly for those of us who
want to see the country right-of-center
you know whether it's the Supreme Court
or 21 Circuit Court judges or
regulations repealed or comprehensive
tax reform just this week alone we
passed a veteran's Choice Act a major
significant piece of legislation the
record of this Congress is quite
spectacular and we'll be able to add
even more achievements throughout the
summer and fully intend to by taking up
the farm bill by taking up the National
Defense Authorization Act and beginning
to function on appropriation bills which
the Democrats ground to a halt last year
we think that's not going to happen this
year yeah I wasn't suggesting that
nothing's getting done I'm suggesting
whether you needed how much more can get
done in that additional time if you
choose to do that if the house
discharges discharge petition on daca
happens and succeeds would you take that
up in the Senate yeah my view on
immigration you may or may not recall
back in February I brought up the
subject of the immigration allowed a
wide open debate with amendments we
spent a week on it on the Senate floor
and passed nothing if there's a bill
that clears the house that President
Trump indicates he would sign then I'll
give it serious consideration because
then we would be making a law and not
just you know spending our wheels for a
week or so I can't afford to do that we
have appropriation bills to pass and
other measures that I just mentioned to
you a few moments ago that will take up
floor time not to mention additional
confirmations of judges and members of
the executive branch that are pending
before us couple more quick things one
is the criticism of the president and
this administration not just coming from
Democrats here is Senator Jeff Flake and
pretty pointed language yesterday your
national leadership is well know
good at all our presidency has been
debased by a figure who seemingly has a
bottomless appetite for destruction and
division and only a passing familiarity
with how the Constitution works and our
article 1 branch of government the
Congress that's me there's uh turley
soup line in the visit in the face of
the moral vandalism that flows from the
White House daily your reaction to that
senator well obviously I don't I don't
agree with that I wish Jeff we're gonna
run again and stay in Congress and try
to have an impact he decided to leave to
retire so he can say what he will I'd
obviously don't agree with that I think
this has been a period of extraordinary
accomplishment by both the president and
the Republican Congress last thing
another Republican senator senator
Toomey tweeting out raising taxes on
Americans who choose to buy imported
cars or trucks is a bad idea doing it
under the false pretense of national
security section
232 is an even worse idea as it invites
retaliation and weakens our credibility
on actual trade disputes it seems like
there's pushback in the Republican ranks
on that as well yeah I tend to agree
with Timmy on that I hope we can avoid
getting into any kind of tariff
situation particularly worried about
retaliation that impacts American
agriculture a place where we enjoy
substantial trade surpluses with the
rest of the world so I think all of us
are hoping that all of this back and
forth discussion about trade doesn't end
up leading us in to the implementation
of tariffs or some larger trade war you
hear anything from Senator McCain I
haven't had a chance to visit him a
couple weeks ago out in Arizona
we had a good discussion about all the
the battles of the past sometimes we
were not on the same side he's a great
American and we wish wish he could come
back
Senator McConnell we appreciate your
time thank you